These no fuss
many cinnamon
scrolls have got me and my whole family in a chokehold.
And Mark my words,
this and every potential variation of this recipe
is gonna be rinsed and repeated for school lunches
throughout 2024.
And my favorite thing about this recipe is
there's no yeast,
so there's no rising time.
So I can just make it,
serve it and be done with it.
Start by sifting two cups of self raising flour
and a pinch of
add 90 grams of softened butter
and rub together with your fingers
before making a well in the middle
and adding two thirds of a cup of milk.
Turn it out onto a well flowered surface
and knead until your dough comes together
and then roll it out into a rough rectangle shape
about half a centimeter thick.
And then prepare your filling.
I went with cinnamon obviously,
but equally
you could do a savory filling
and make something like pizza scroll.
For my filling,
I mixed 120 grams of butter,
a quarter of a cup of brown sugar,
two teaspoons of white sugar
and one and a/2 teaspoons of cinnamon.
And when I said that this recipe was easy,
I wasn't kidding.
You just smear your filling all over that dough
and roll it up
because I want these to be the
perfect size for the lunch box.
I've greased a mini muffin tin to make it easier.
And I went to chop my log into 12 pieces
and I Only ended up with 11.
So my meth wasn't methane,
which meant my triggers were triggered. Anyway,
pop your little scroll babies into the oven at 180
degrees C for about 20 to 25 minutes
until they've risen and golden.
And meanwhile,
I made my icing,
which was just one cup of icing sugar to two
tablespoons of boiling water.
Your family doesn't eat them all at once like mine
totally would if I let them.
They should keep in the pantry for about 2 or 3 days
if stored properly.
And this is where the Glad Snap Lock
resellable sandwich bags are ideal.
Seal changes from blue to green
so that you know that it's sealed tight,
locking that freshness.
And one thing that I'm trying to get better at
this year is preparing some lunch box items in
advance to make the mom life
chaos a little bit more manageable in the morning.
So if you make a double batch,
just individually wrap them in your glad cling wrap
and then freeze.